Time,
but when you just did and it's going to get there and I can't fucking wait when
he goes,
I am ready for heavyweight.
Hendrick's Francis,
what are we going to do?
What are we going to do?
Kimber steep.
A cane.
Well they're probably Lesnar deal doesn't get done.
The talk is steep a versus DC cause the Brock Lesnar deal is not done now in
that whole process.
Cause Prost no that's not real.
What WWE fuck he didn't know.
I thought it was real.
I'm sorry.
Do you see game of Thrones?
I'll give you some more spoiled dude.
I bet your sweet ass.
I don't talk about it.
People get angry.
Now there are dragons,
DVR and dragons.
A real um,
they think that you see Steve Bay to rock might not fight.
They don't know.
Like Brock has to decide this is something he definitely wants to do.
Quit fucking given us blue balls and get the fuck in there.
I get the fuck out now.
He's got to make the commitment.
And I know he's been training,
he's been training and training.
Yeah.
And he's trained with some high level wrestlers.
I Hoe Michigan's DC July.
What's up?
Yeah.
And then July content stack.
You've got to be careful with Brock memory tag.
Randy coture and dropped him and hammer fist at him into oblivion.
He was 48 years old,
but I hear Ya.
I hear Ya.
I like you're selling me on these flights.
Never how he smashed Frank Mir.
Yes.
Terrifying.
That was remarried.
Him and freight Caden each other and each fucked frank up.
Well,
it's because frank got him with that knee bar and he didn't,
he uh,
he tapped the referee didn't stop it to,
it's a stupid miotic not blocked Brock Lesnar next and like,
oh,
when did this happen?
Like the preconference maybe.
Oh Wow.
But he's,
but that's just the headline.
He goes,
we don't know what Brooke's going to do,
but if it doesn't happen,
it's steep bay.
Oh,
this just one of them.
They got us.
They got you.
They got us better.
John Means am credit worked.
If we could listen too click baity farmers,
they got us.
I love Steve Bape steep ADC.
I'm like,
alright,
yeah,
yeah.
I need something spicy,
man.
I,
I get what you're saying and I get the Brock Lesnar appeal.
I would rather see steep,
steep it,
you know,
like,
cause you're a purist and that's why I like you,
but not me.
I'm like depressed Hilton of MMA,
not me sir.
Out of respect,
because I know he deserves it.
He Won.
He defended the title more than any human being that's ever held it.
He's the number one guy in the heavyweight division.
So you have to rate him the greatest heavyweight of all time.
If you look about accomplishments,
he's the greatest UFC heavyweight of all time.
He sees in terms of accomplishments,
just because he's done it four times.
Okay.
You know,
DC beat him.
Obviously DC is supposed to mean if you,
if you had to rank him,
you know,
like right now,
like one through 10 thank [inaudible] Frank Gcs,
number one,
because he's the champion and knocked him out to say he's number two.
It'd be silly,
but to say like the all time,
greatest,
most accomplished heavyweight [inaudible] CTCs.
Okay.
The all time most accomplished greatest heavyweight is DPA.
You gotta count.
Well,
Kane never defended as many times as steep paid did.
The question is,
did Cain beat the better guys?
Did he beat junior dos Santos when junior was young?
He,
before he had been through those wars with Kane.
Right.
Because by the time Steve Bay got him,
Jr had been in some wars in junior has like really good late.
He looks amazing.
But you can never discount the,
that damage you can.
I'm not saying that he's not as good now.
I think he's still phenomenal now.
But the Bam Bam to Ivanka fight knocking out that [inaudible] toughest shit man
knocking that motherfucker out.
And the way he did it,
he looks good man.
Dude is as good as jds a Francis of ESPN code.
That's not a paper view.
I think that's fucking does ESPN I think so to a fucking can you do and do him
around and um,
he fought Derrick Lewis,
right?
Yeah.
Stop Derrick Lewis.
Stop.
They're close.
Yeah.
Look,
junior dos Santos still is an amazing fighter.
That's something she'll like.
Ah,
ah.
So I'm going to watch it when Steve a beat.
But you know what,
Steve Bacon knock anybody out like that too.
It's hard to say.
You know what the problem is with Steve Bay,
the prom is DC's fought what?
Twice since their fight Steve.
But he's just been chilling.
Boy,
he's been wanting this rematch.
Weight Guy.
Got It.
I get it.
But,
but it's a risky thing when you're a former heavyweight champion and you're
going to take a fight when you rightfully deserve a rematch.
And what if you get hurt while you're taking this fight?
What have you,
you know you have this fight and you get hurt and then you have knee surgery,
then you're out for another year and then DC loses it in DC retires,
he wants to fight him again and the way to fight him again is to hold out,
hold out this whole time.
I don't know.
Obviously the UFC wants to fight DC again.
That's the way it seems a little now in hindsight cause lesser.
That happened in John Joseph not going a heavyweight but he's the third choice
and all this.
Well I thought waiting for that.
I thought it was very interested in,
is it John said that to Steve Bay that John,
I don't think it's weird if which align thing.
The same thing we do with style bender.
He's just fucking with everybody.
He's getting his name out there.
He's learning from Connor C I think there's more to it.
I think UFC was fishing and went,
hey,
you down in the fight steepen tenement y'all fuck ups depot and then what?
Steep.
Identify Johnny when Y'all fuck up John?
I think there's more to it.
You think so?
Yeah.
What makes you say that?
I don't know.
No reason at all.
Maybe they did have some preliminary discussions as to whether or not the two
would engage in fisticuffs.
Maybe they did.
That's a great fight.
Great fight.
Stinks preserves it 100% he deserves big fights,
man.
Look,
the guy doesn't deserve to be forgotten.
No,
not at all.
But Francis in Gando fight was one of the most impressive heavyweight title
defenses because Francis was on fire.
He was so dangerous because they have Francis ranked ahead of him now.
Just be disrespectful,
but Francis has done work.
Steve Bay's got gotta be the number one contender.
Know what?
B D Steve Bay's number one?
Yeah.
Come after Barry.
Have to be,
you never know what's running half to be.
Have to be France.
Steeply.
Your Francis.
Yeah.
For Steve Baby Francis.
It's that simple.
Steve may be junior.
Yeah.
I mean,
come on,
man.
Dude.
Francis dos Santos.
Oh my God.
Dude.